i love oversaturated markets because
that tells you there's a huge
opportunity
and your goal is well how do you
separate yourself from the crowd and
that's
that's why i spent the past two years
putting this information into the hook
point book
but for me for from my perspective
is mastering the art of the thumbnail
and headline
that's the first place that i start now
obviously does the content have to back
it up and be good
yes but if you can't master the way
to get somebody to click or to pay
attention out of the
and i don't know how many are on the
right hand side for suggested video
whether it's five or ten
if you can't stack up against that and
contextualize your headline and
thumbnail in such a way
where the consumer or the viewer says i
have
to click on this i have to see what this
is about
it's gonna be an even tougher battle
welcome to the think marketing podcast
where we help you grow your influence
with youtube and then take that
influence and turn it into a high impact
and high
profit online business my name is
heather torres and i'm excited that
you're here if you're new here
consider subscribing wherever you're
consuming this content we bring you a
brand new episode
every single tuesday we call it tuesday
ritual
and we'd love for you to be a part of
our community here well today's
conversation
is actually part of our series all about
the books you need to be reading
this year we already did the podcast of
the five books every content creator and
youtuber should read this year
and i'm excited because shawn is going
to be interviewing
one of the authors of one of those books
now we are going
in depth all about hook points and you
might be wondering
hook points what is that and why is it
important as a content creator
well sean will be sitting down with the
author interviewing him
all about how this applies to you as a
content creator so you can grab
attention
get views and grow your channel well
let's
dive into today's featured conversation
welcome back to the think marketing
podcast sean cannell here and i'm so
fired up because today i've got the
author of hook
point brendan kane joining the show this
is one of my
top recommended books of 2020 i think
it's a must read book
for all entrepreneurs business owners
and especially content creators and
youtube creators
going into 2021 brendan how's it going
it's going awesome thanks uh for having
me sean it's pleasure to connect with
you and everybody that's
listening and watching us for sure
thanks so much for uh jumping on the
podcast and i'm excited for the value
today you know we teach all the time
that you got to get people's attention
before they can even watch your content
you have to have a powerful title you
have to have a powerful thumbnail
you have to have a powerful opening to
your video and i'm excited for you to
break down some strategies
from your book hook point and of course
we'll link it up in the show notes
um and uh description and this is a must
pick up book
but before we dive into it like what are
kind of the big picture challenges
that business owners entrepreneurs and
creators are facing going into
2021 and basically why this book and why
now
yeah great question so as you know sean
better than anybody the world has
completely changed and it's completely
shifted
the world that we live in today looks
like that there's over 60
billion messages sent out on digital
platforms each day
between email push notifications social
media content
it's a very noisy and over saturated
world
and because of that the world that we
live in today you're no longer
competing against your direct
competition you're competing against
everybody
like it or not you're competing against
netflix you're competing against kevin
hart the rock kim kardashian
all of these people so as we go into
2021
it's you've got to look at content from
that perspective
is how can my content stack up or
or win that attention against every
other piece that's being published
and that's where a hook point comes in
we talk a lot about pattern interruption
is if you're on youtube or instagram or
any of these social platforms
and they just watch kevin hart tell a
joke or they watch joe rogan's podcast
or they watch kim kardashian talk about
fashion and then your content's there
how are you going to get somebody to
stop just stop
and say listen i want to dig in further
i want to see what this is all about
that's crazy it feels a little bit
overwhelming and you even put it in the
subtitle
how to stand out in a three-second world
like how do we get people to stop
and what can't where did you come up
with three seconds from
yeah so i came up with three seconds
based upon one of you was counted
so if you remember way back in the day i
don't even remember how long ago this
must be like six or seven years ago but
on the facebook advertising platform
advertisers used to get charged at the
one second mark
and advertisers were up in arms about it
because they're like well that shows
no intent it's like people could scroll
past not even see any part of the video
and you're still counting it as a view
so everybody really
shifted to this concept of registering a
view at least
three seconds so that's where we came up
with this three second
mark and a lot of the metrics that we
look at
specifically when we're focusing on
going viral on instagram
facebook tic tac or linkedin we look at
the ratio
between views to reach because again
reach doesn't
necessarily mean you're generating a
view so
we look at that ratio on those platforms
and we're aiming for a
bare minimum of 30 percent uh 40
is our target goal and anything over 40
percent the algorithms are going to love
you
and give you more reach now youtube as
you know sean it's it's different
uh you're going after that click through
so you're looking at that click through
percentage and that counts as
are you capturing somebody in less than
three seconds where it correlates
to that click on your thumbnail and
headline for suggested
videos and if it doesn't generate that
click obviously you're not getting
anybody into the videos
and the algorithms are not going to
favor and give you more reach and
distribution
and for somebody that lots of
if they listen to a marketing podcast if
they watch different people
teaching on how to break through on
social media the word algorithms
is thrown around all the time yeah if
you were going to try to break down
algorithms simply um to how they work
today
as we know it in kind of layman's term
so that we can be best positioned to
manipulate or win with the algorithms
how would you explain it
yeah and that's that's a great point
because there's so much misconception
there's so much
misinformation about it the way that i
treat and look at algorithms is
they just have a job and you got to
understand what that job
is to understand how to play to it so
the algorithm's job
is to keep people on the platform as
long as possible because that's how
these platforms
make money so what the algorithm is
there to do
is to prioritize and find the content
that is going to keep each individual
user on the platforms longer
so let's imagine that we open up youtube
there's probably a thousand videos that
could see to you
based upon your search what you've
searched before
based on the channels you've subscribed
to based on the videos that you watched
previously
so with all of that content it could
potentially see to this specific
individual
well it's got to prioritize what are the
top 10
15 pieces of content that i believe
is going to keep this specific user on
the platform longer
so when we design content for the
algorithms
it comes down to two things it's very
simple two things one
do you get somebody to stop on on
facebook instagram
tick tock linkedin do you get somebody
to stop the scroll
and that view to reach ratio i talked
about on youtube is does it generate the
click
and then once we have the attention it
goes to the second thing is how long do
you hold that attention for
if you can one get somebody to click or
to stop the scroll
and two hold their attention for a long
period of time
the algorithms will love you and they'll
give you massive reach and massive
distribution and that's really
how content creators can go viral in the
world that we live in today
so powerful and enter your book hook
point
so that's our goal how do we get people
to stop and then how do we get people to
stay
so what exactly is a hook point then and
what are kind of the basic elements
yeah so a hook point has three core
pillars to it
and at the highest level a hook point is
solving for this is grabbing attention
so the first core pillar is that pattern
interrupt how do we get somebody to just
stop and pay attention to us it's not
about expressing everything that we're
about
just how do we grab that attention and
that first one to three seconds
so that we have the right to earn that
click we have that right to stop that
scroll
which goes into the second core pillar
which what is the story that you're
gonna tell
now that you have the attention how are
you going to hold it
now this is a big difference mate some
people may be saying well is this click
bait well the big difference between
click bait is the story typically
doesn't
match up to the way that you grabbed
that attention
so that's the second core pillar what is
the story how long can we hold that
attention for
and then the third core pillar is do
people believe
what we're saying do they trust it so if
we look at those three core pillars
together
without that pattern eruption without
that getting them to stop
you never get to the story if you get
people to stop and click
but your story your content's not good
and you don't retain it it falls apart
now if you grab attention and you tell a
compelling story but people don't
believe it they don't trust it
then it falls apart so all three of
these have to play together
in order to create a successful hook
point and really stand out in today's
world
and what's one of your favorite
illustrations or a story that
illustrates a well-executed
hook point well there's so many i mean
we had i'll give you an example of
we talk about subverting expectations of
the book so we did
a video on social in in all caps that
said warning
safety is dangerous so what we did is we
flipped that misconception on the head
to grab people's attention now if we
want to talk about the
youtube ecosystem some of the best
content creators are
masters at hook points mr beast
by far one of the smartest guys in terms
of those hook points
yes theory another great channel that
focuses on a topic of seeking discomfort
but they do it in such a way with hooks
and compelling ways to bring people into
the attention
you want to talk about the biggest
podcasts in the world
joe rogan you look at his clips channel
they are masters at finding hooks within
the interviews
they do so powerful
and for somebody that's like okay so
i get the hook point and i'm gonna pick
up the book so i can dive deeper into
the elements and master these
um but there's something that as
business owners and content creators
we also eventually will come across of
like things we need
what is our usp if you're a business
owner what's your unique selling
position
then also like what's your tagline like
i say i help people build their
influence with youtube
um and then make how are you different
in the market or then also what's your
mission like the mission of our company
is to help 10 000 purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with youtube a little bit
longer
and i took longer than three seconds to
say that and and so you have like these
different pieces
where do each of these pieces kind of
fall in place and how are they different
or are they different than the hook
point yeah so
sometimes your mission statement or your
tagline
or your usp can be hook points now most
of the time that's not the case
i'll give you an example is like
instacart groceries delivered in less
than an hour
that is their usp but it is also
their hook point but most of the time
it's not falling into that
i really look at the hook point as a way
to get people
into your brand get them into your
tagline get them
into your mission statement and
companies
content creators brands they can all
have
multiple hook points into their service
so to give you an example of that you
look at netflix and netflix today
invests over 17 billion dollars
uh in content every single year
why because each one of those pieces of
content is a hook
point into their brand into their
subscription
and the same goes for a content creator
youtube content creator and in the brand
that you built sean
so amazingly is each one of your videos
serves as a hook point into your
ecosystem
where they can dive deeper into your
tagline or your mission statement and i
think people
oftentimes get that mixed up as there
can be multiple hooks into your brand
and then you get them into those other
elements
yeah and to me that sounds in a way the
way i've
been thinking about hook point
especially loving the book just
devouring it marking every page
sharing it with our team having them
read it and again recommend it's in our
top five books to read this year to grow
on youtube
and i really feel like it's a critical
tool especially if you want to crack
through on youtube but it's just kind of
a modern skill set i feel like if you're
going to be a modern entrepreneur a
modern small business owner you're
trying to get attention you're trying to
stand out you're trying to get noticed
and it kind of reminds me a lot about
copywriting like writing persuasive
marketing copy like what's the point of
the email subject
line just to get someone to open the
email what's the point of the first word
to get someone to read the second word
what's the point of the second word
just to get someone to read the third
world word and the mistake is that
well the point of the first word or the
email subject line is to get one
somebody to read the whole email
you you jump too far ahead there you
actually just always need that next step
and so if you sort of it's kind of like
dating right if you if you
spill everything all at once it's like
yo this is speed dating i'm just meeting
you it's the first night like let the
story
unfold so am i correct to think that
with a hook point we're trying to get
attention
maybe even with one sub demo sub
niche sub target audience get their
attention now we're communicating
the story can unfold a little more but
we don't need to unpack our whole life
story
in that moment because ideally there's
going to be a customer journey
on our youtube channel and one video
might just be the start of a
relationship
how do you think about hook points in
terms of people kind of building out
their entire
customer journey yeah i mean you
eloquently put it
it's it's earning the right to the next
part of the conversation and
and you hit it on the head as most
people where they struggle or why
they're failing is they jump
too in so it's like that analogy you
said on the date as they're proposing on
the first date
or they're revealing all their deepest
darkest secrets or
desires on that first date where you
have to essentially earn the right
to bring that in and also you you
brought up some
other good points is when we look at
hook points it can be
many different things like it could be a
visual in terms of an
image with no words it can be words
sometimes when we're developing hook
points for clients it's a strategy
it's a business development strategy of
how do we how do we
acquire the attention of this one ceo
that if we close it represents 50
million dollars in deals
or how do we grab the attention of this
celebrity to endorse our product
or to partner us with us also there's
it can be a performance like princier
who wrote the forward for my first book
one of the top inspirational video
creators on the planet
his hook is his performance you know he
has like
he has one video on the environment that
has over 110 million views
and he's not saying anything different
than anybody else in the environmental
space
it's the way that he contextualized the
performance
to hook people into him and hint into
his brand
so so many people think about a hook oh
it's
just copy yes copy is one part of it
but it can be so many different elements
it could be your product yourself like
we talk about elon musk
and tesla and what he did with the cyber
truck and the way that he designed it to
create this polarized reaction
is it beautiful is it ugly and he
designed that
on purpose as a hook into the tesla
brand
and to generate record-setting
pre-orders for for that truck
man powerful examples well for
a youtube creator especially going into
2021
um it feels overwhelming is it too
crowded it's hard to stand out yet we
see in our brand
and with the students we help and the
viewers and people in our community
there are those breakout videos you're
really always one breakout video you're
one breakout piece of content
it may eventually be a couple sometimes
a viral video doesn't change your life
it gives you kind of 15 minutes and then
you still got to get back to the grind
but what kind of advice would you give
for applying hook point
specifically in a youtube world and for
somebody that
feels like it's an up here hill battle
david versus goliath
with how much content there is out there
on youtube if somebody wanted to get
their
brand their videos their business
noticed
yeah is it an uphill battle yes but to
me
i love oversaturated markets because
that tells you there's a huge
opportunity
and your goal is well how do you
separate yourself from the crowd and
that's
that's why i spent the past two years
putting this information into the hook
point book
but for me for from my perspective
is mastering the art of the thumbnail
and headline
that's the first place that i start now
obviously does the content have to back
it up and be good
yes but if you can't master the way
to get somebody to click or to pay
attention out of the
and i don't know how many are on the
right hand side for suggested video
whether it's five or ten
if you can't stack up against that and
contextualize your headline and
thumbnail in such a way
where the consumer or the viewer says i
have
to click on this i have to see what this
is about
it's gonna be an even tougher battle so
where i would start is really study the
master study mr beast yes theory
ryan sirhand and sean study your
channels as well
and look at how they're positioning it
but when we look at channels especially
the high performers
we don't just look at the the highest
performing
content on their channel we look at
their lowest performing as well
and we see well why is this at the high
performing
working but their lowest performing
videos what's the difference there
was it in the thumbnail was it in the
headline was it
the way that they tried to build
retention and become a student of that
first because it will help you shape the
rest of the content that you produce
it's like when i start with a book or i
start crafting a keynote
or even with a social video i'm always
starting with the hook
of how i'm going to get somebody to stop
and then i design the content
around that hook powerful
um if we want to get into just maybe a
few triggers
and the book is packed full of
some like frameworks that could get us
thinking if it's like okay
i want to get attention i want to start
with the hook what are some starting
points
for listeners um you mentioned one which
was subverting
expectations one of the examples i loved
in the book as well
was you were promoting some kind of a
meditation thing and you were talking
about
meditation doesn't work it's kind of
going the opposite but then when in fact
you were like just coming from a
different perspective
what are maybe just a handful if i still
feel like okay
i want to have a more powerful hook next
time you get me started and then i'll
kind of like
put my niche into these uh
frames of starting a hook point
absolutely
so let me complete that meditation
example that you brought up because i
think it's a great one
is if i was going to subvert
expectations and again it's flipping it
on its head
is i have to look at meditation and this
is a big problem that most people run
into when they're creating content
is they're saying the same thing in the
same way
as everybody else so meditation's been
around for thousands of years if you
type it into google there's going to be
billions of results
and people will say the same thing well
meditation is the key to success or
meditation is the key to stillness or
contentment or happiness
the minute i see that i already know
what it's going to be about even if you
have a unique
spin on it i just look at it and from my
micro attention
mind here i'm going to say well i
already know what this is about so i
don't need to watch it
so subverting expectations is one great
tool of doing that
so when we talk about meditation i may
create an ad or an organic piece of
content that says
at the top or the thumbnail or headline
meditation is a scam
and then i'll dive in and say hey have
you ever felt like meditation is a scam
or it just hasn't worked for you
well i feel your pain because when i
first started meditating
i tried everything people were telling
me i just sit down and clear my head
and every time i sat down my mind would
race and i thought
am i doing something wrong is meditation
broken or even worse is meditation's a
scam
so today i want to show you three tips
of me as a non-meditator that allowed me
to meditate every day for the past 10
years
so let's dive in so that's one tactic
and tool
another one that my friend craig
clemens one of the top copyrighters in
the world that sold over a billion
dollars of the products we
interviewed for the book he says
something really brilliant
he says the minute that you can
articulate
somebody's greatest pain point
somebody's greatest anxiety
better than they can articulate it to
themselves you're going to win that
trust you're going to win
that attention so oftentimes when i'm
working with clients i ask them
what is keeping your core audience up at
night
what is consciously what are they
thinking about not subconsciously what
you think they need
but what is it that they want and tap
into that
which leads to another aspect that i
walk people through is
especially really brilliant and
successful people struggle this
is you got to understand that there's a
big difference between
what people need and what people
want and most people are starting with
what people
need and the viewer or the consumer is
just not there yet
or you gotta t you know tap into the
want
so just give you an example that with my
first book 1 million followers how i
built a massive social audience in 30
days
i was tapping into what
people want which is followers they want
social growth
but what i know what they need they need
to know how to test
content they need to understand a hook
point they need to understand strategic
partnerships and alliances
they need to understand how to create
shareable content but if i
led with that it would fall flat so
oftentimes if you're a content creator
really make that distinction for
yourself if i am i promoting something
that
that that somebody really needs that i
believe they need
and are they even there yet or do i need
to start with something that they want
in life and
yes theory is a perfect example of that
of seeking discomfort
people are not walking around or
searching google saying i'm seeking
discomfort
so they wrap that contextually with
great hooks
like taking uh a first tinder date
around the world
you know becoming superman with wim wim
hof the iceman i don't know that's the
exact title
but look at youtube's uh or look at yes
there is youtube channel and you can see
how they took
something that they knew the world needs
but they don't lead with it they wrap it
in what people
want which is fun feeling
facts interesting things
man brilliant make the smart move and
pick up the book
hook point literally one of my favorite
books especially in a youtube creator
type of world
and that is in the show notes of course
and uh consume it mark it up
there's so many powerful tactics i want
to thank you for writing the book and
um you know all even the book itself
was records recommended to me on amazon
the title
something that i've studied for years uh
grabbed me the subtitle grabbed me
and we called it a think media and i'm
sure somebody else said it
uh the chocolate covered carrot it's the
chocolate man i want to get the
attention in three seconds well the
carrot is the vegetables the nutrition
there's the thing i actually want is the
easy way to get attention but what i
need
is the strategy and the thought process
and the a b testing and already
you know if you said how how to do
tedious a b
testing in order to build a business up
you'll be like okay well i'm going to
yeah that one so i love the fact of uh
just how powerful the book
is and do want to recommend everyone to
pick it up um
tell me about how people can connect
with you and um you also have an agency
so what are you up to and how are you
helping people
yeah so we're dedicating uh all of our
time to helping people
develop hook points like when we talk
about
thumbnails and headlines we feel that
everybody needs a thumbnail and headline
for their business for their brand for
their product
their service and again we've worked
with startups we've worked with billion
dollar corporations we've worked with
major celebrities
and the one thing that reoccurring theme
across them is they're all
struggling in this new world that we
live in to conceptualize what they do
what their genius is
in a very succinct and eye-catching way
so they can win the first part of the
conversation
so we created a consulting firm called
hook point at you can go to
hookpoint.com
where we help people actually develop
these hook points help them stand out
whether it's online or offline yes we
have a lot of success with social media
we will also have tremendous success
doing b2b
doing closing major partnerships and in
strategic licensing deals
and all of that so we use our 15 years
of experience in the space to help and
guide the strategy
of how to capitalize on attention
to drive your business goals going
forward so people can check out
hookpoint.com and if you want to check
out the hookpoint book i recommend going
to book.hookpoint.com
because you get a free masterclass with
it uh but people can reach out to me
directly on instagram at brendan kane
or email me at b kane at
brendenjkane.com as well
brendan kane the book is hook point i
appreciate you so much for coming on and
adding so much value to the think
marketing podcast
today and uh looking forward to
connecting in the future and all the
different
work you're putting out into the world i
appreciate it and grateful for you
yeah thank you so much for having me and
thanks everybody for listening to this i
really appreciate it
well i hope you are as fired up as i am
to
dive deeper into this book i will admit
i'm only four chapters in but i
am marked it up like crazy this book to
me
has been so impactful and just
understanding how to grab
attention you know when i was reviewing
this interview with uh my son
he was telling me about the titles and
the thumbnails that he likes to click on
when he's on youtube and it just
inspired me to know that it doesn't
matter what type of content you're
creating
this applies to you and it is it's all
about attention
and remember as a content creator one of
the most
underutilized parts of your youtube
channel is probably your analytics
this is where you can dive into and you
can see more and more about what is
working on your channel rather than just
throwing up the next video
why don't you take some time today
tomorrow or this week
to dive into what is working what videos
are blowing up and why and i love how
brendan said
what videos aren't working and why i
think it's important as content creators
that we take the time to really assess
or we we call it here at think media
zero base our content you might be
emotionally attached to the content
you're creating and think that your art
is wonderful
but if people are not connecting with it
on the other side of their screens
if they're not clicking through if
they're not actually consuming your
content
well then i think it's good to take a
sober evaluation of what really is
working
look at your competitors look at other
people on youtube that you want to be
like that you want to emulate and see
what videos are working for them i think
that also
you know youtube takes time this is a
marathon not a sprint
and when you just start out on youtube
it may feel
discouraging like what when's it gonna
break through when am i going to pop off
when can i get to
100 000 a million subscribers when does
that happen
this is a process and that process is a
whole cyclical piece that we teach here
at think media
in our seven step system and if you've
not already taken the master class where
you learned the secrets to success on
youtube
then i actually recommend that that be
your next step after this podcast
go over and register for our free
youtube class where we give you
the tools that you need to be successful
on youtube this year you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com
to register for that one hour free class
where we're going to help you jumpstart
your channel well we're going to help
you go deeper if you are already started
and where we're going to help give you
some gasoline to the fire
of the youtube channel that you want to
grow and again that's at
thinkmasterclass.com also if you have
not already
left a review on our podcast that would
mean the world to me for you to do that
all you need to do
is go to apple itunes if you're
listening to it right now
on the app just leave a review rate the
podcast and that helps
other creators just like you discover
this podcast and
i love to read the different reviews
that are on the podcast and this one
comes from
jj peller and jj says amazingly
high value i'm obsessed hey jj i'm
obsessed too
uh i've listened to five episodes in the
past three days
so much value thank you for sharing such
amazing ideas
and insights and strategies to help me
restart
uh to help me restart fast with youtube
as i relaunch my channel in 2021
joyfully jj
peller jj i just want to encourage you
to keep going we've got a whole library
of content here on the podcast
and then we also have the think media
channel to help you grow
with the tech and the gear and all the
things that you need to make
amazing videos and thank you so much jj
for being a part of our community and
for
listening in and i can't wait to see
what happens to your channel in 2021
well
thank you so much for being here for
this episode it means the world to us
that you give us your time
and i can't wait for you to hear the
next episode but if you haven't
make sure you check out the master class
at thinkmasterclass.com
and we'll catch it in the next episode
[Music]
you